HAPPENED AT 8:00 P.M.
SEAN HANNITY IS NEXT.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
FOX NEWS ALERT AND BREAKING NOW,
THIS IS HUGE.
THE FISA COURT JUST ISSUED AN
EXTREMELY RARE REBUKE PUBLIC
ORDER REBUKING COMEY'S FBI FOR
MISLEADING THE COURT.
THIS FISA JUDGE IS DEMANDING THE
FBI COME UP WITH A PROPOSAL TO
PREVENT ANOTHER MASSIVE ABUSE OF
POWER.
THIS IS THE LATEST FALLOUT FROM
THE IG'S DAMNING FISA ABUSE
REPORTS.
WE'LL HAVE THE DETAILS THAT THE
MOB AND THE MEDIA WILL PROBABLY
IGNORE BECAUSE THEY MISSED THE
WHOLE STORY.
RETURN TO THE WASHINGTON SWAMP.
DEMOCRATS HAVE DECIDED A TOXIC
POLITICAL STUD IS OBVIOUSLY MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE RULE OF LAW.
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC,
BASIC FAIRNESS, DUE PROCESS, OUR
GREAT CONSTITUTION AND THE WILL
OF WE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BREAKING MOMENTS AGO, THE
PRESIDENT IS FIGHTING BACK.
A POWERFUL, SCATHING BEAT DOWN.
THE PRESIDENT ACCUSED
SPEAKER PELOSI OF DECLARING OPEN
WAR ON AMERICAN DEMOCRACY WITH A
PARTISAN IMPEACHMENT CRUSADE
THAT REPRESENTS AN UNPRECEDENTED
AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL ABUSE OF
POWER BY DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS.
WITH MORE DUE PROCESS OF ONE OF
THOSE ACCUSED IN THE SALEM WITCH
TRIALS.
THE PRESIDENT WENT ON TO UTTERLY
DESTROY THE PELOSI AND THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE SCHIFF AND THE
NUTTY NADLER SCHIFF SHOWING THE
IDIOTIC ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT
WRITING "YOUR FIRST CLAIM, ABUSE
OF POWER.
IT'S A COMPLETE DISINGENUOUS
MERITLESS BASELESS INVENTION OF
YOUR IMAGINATION.
THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED "YOU ARE
TRYING TO IMPEACH ME BY FALSELY
ACCUSING ME OF DOING WHAT
JOE BIDEN HAS ADMITTED HE
ACTUALLY DID."
THE PRESIDENT ALSO SHREDDING
PELOSI'S SECOND CLAIM, THE
SO-CALLED OBSTRUCTION OF
CONGRESS, CALLING A PREPOSTEROUS
AND DANGEROUS.
WHAT DO WE SAY?
WE HAVE THREE BRANCHES OF
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH,
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH HAVE A
CONFLICT, YES, THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH IN THIS CASE HAS A RIGHT
TO SEEK REMEDY IN THE OTHER
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT, KNOWN AS
THE JUDICIARY.
BY THE WAY, CONFIRM WITH THEM
TAKING UP THE CASE LAST WEEK,
3 FOR 3, JAY SEKULOW AND THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS.
THROUGHOUT HISTORY, PRESIDENTS
IN BOTH PARTIES HAVE ALL
ASSERTED EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THE COURTS DECIDE.
THEY ARE THE ARBITER WHEN THERE
ARE THESE CONFLICTS WITH OTHER
BRANCHES AND BY THE WAY, THEY
WILL DECIDE IF THIS PRIVILEGE IS
VALID.
THE COURTS WERE NEVER GIVEN A
CHANCE.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN
THIS BREATHLESS RUSH TO IMPEACH,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
AS THE PRESIDENT'S LETTER
RIGHTLY POINTS OUT,
CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR JONATHAN
TURLEY MADE ONE THING VERY CLEAR
DURING HIS TESTIMONY.
IF DEMOCRATS IMPEACH A SITTING
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
FOR GOING TO THE COURTS TO SEEK
RESOLUTION WHEN THERE IS A
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE OTHER
BRANCHES, THAT WOULD BE AN ABUSE
OF POWER.
THAT WOULD BE CONGRESSES ABUSE
SO THE CIRCUS, THE SCHIFF SHOW
ON CAPITOL HILL FULL OF CORRUPT
POLITICAL STUNT AFTER STUNT.
THIS WILL FOREVER STAY NOT ONLY
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT THIS
HURTS WE THE PEOPLE.
REMEMBER THEY DON'T LIKE WHO WE
CHOSE IN 2016, WHO YOU CHOSE IN
2016.
THE SPEAKER IN NAME ONLY NAME
NANCY PELOSI, PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONCLUDED "HISTORY WILL JUDGE
YOU HARSHLY AS YOU PROCEED WITH
THIS IMPEACHMENT CHARADE.
YOUR LEGACY WILL BE THAT OF
TURNING THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM A REVERED
LEGISLATIVE BODY INTO A STAR
CHAMBER OF PARTISAN
PERSECUTION."
TONIGHT THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IS
UNFOLDING IN THIS COUNTRY.
DRIVEN BY IRRATIONAL RAGE AND
PSYCHOTIC HATRED, THIS RADICAL
EXTREME NEW SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NANCY PELOSI IS NOW SET TO RAM
THIS IMPEACHMENT THROUGH ON A
PARTY LINE VOTE.
SHE HAS BEEN TRYING FOR ONLY TWO
AND HALF YEARS.
CONGRESSWOMAN MAXINE WATERS, HER
DREAMS OF IMPEACHING 45 ARE
ABOUT TO COME TRUE FOR NOTHING
THOUGH.
THE SQUAD, I ASSUME THEY ARE
JUMPING FOR JOY.
CORRUPT.
THE COMPROMISE.
THE CONGENITAL LIAR ADAM SCHIFF
I GUESS HE WILL PAT HIMSELF ON
THE BACK.
THE CELEBRATION HOWEVER, THAT
WILL BE SHORT-LIVED BECAUSE THE
DEMOCRATS, THERE HYPERPARTISAN
BLOOD LUST AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THIS WILL HAVE
REPERCUSSIONS AND DIRE POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES IN THE END.
BUT NOT FOR THE PRESIDENT.
HE WILL NOT BE CONVICTED IN THE
SENATE.
THAT'S WHERE REPUBLICANS HOLD
THE MAJORITY AND THAT'S WHERE
YOU WILL NEED REAL FACT
WITNESSES, NOT HEARSAY WITNESSES
AND OPINION PEOPLE.
WE SEE THE BEGINNINGS OF THIS
DEMISE HAPPENING ON UNFOLDING
RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT'S POLL
NUMBERS.
BRAND-NEW "USA TODAY" POLL SHOWS
THE PRESIDENT EASILY DEFEATING
EVERYONE OF HIS HIS POTENTIAL
2020 RIVALS.
ANOTHER POLL, FAKE NEWS CNN OF
ALL PLACES.
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN IMPEACHMENT
SUPPORT FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
ACCORDING TO THAT SURVEY,
IMPEACHMENT IS LEAVING LOSING
SUPPORT AMONG REGISTERED
DEMOCRATS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, AS CONGRESSMAN
DOUG COLLINS POINTED OUT TODAY,
THERE WILL BE A RECKONING THE
GOOD NEWS IS IN 322 DAYS YOU,
WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, WE
TRUMP SUPPORTING THE SMELLY
WALMART SHOPPERS, THOSE OF US TO
BELIEVE IN GOD, OUR
CONSTITUTION, OUR BIBLES,
RELIGION, IRREDEEMABLE
DEPLORABLES, YOU GET THE LAST
WORD IN 322 DAYS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WILL REMIND MY MAJORITY
FRIENDS AND I DO CONSIDER YOU
FRIENDS, THE CLOCK IN THE
CALENDAR ARE TERRIBLE MASTERS
AND THEY LEAD TO AWFUL RESULTS.
AND YES, THERE WILL BE A DAY OF
RECKONING.
THE CALENDAR THE CLOCK WILL
CONTINUE.
BUT WHAT YOU DO HERE AND HOW WE
HAVE TRASHED THE PROCESS IN
GETTING HERE WILL LIVE ON.
AND IT WILL AFFECT EVERYTHING
THAT WE HAVE COME FOR.
SO WHATEVER YOU MAY GAIN WILL BE
SHORT-LIVED BECAUSE THE CLOCK ON
THE CALENDAR ALSO RECOGNIZE
COMMON SENSE WHICH IS NOT BEEN
USED IN THIS PROCEEDINGS.
>> Sean: ON NOVEMBER 3, 2020,
YOU, WE, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
YOU DECIDE IF THIS CHARADE,
TIME, MONEY ENERGY WAS WELL
SPENT.
IMAGINE CNN FAKE NEWS CANAL
PROJECT DONALD J. TRUMP HAS BEEN
REELECTED.
THE 45TH PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, YOU
CAN MAKE THAT HAPPEN.
NEARLY EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER APPARENTLY WILLING TO
WALK THE PLANK FOR PELOSI.
RECENT HEADLINE: LEFT-WING
"NEW YORK TIMES" "MODERATE
DEMOCRATS BACK IMPEACHMENT OF
TRUMP AS HOUSE VOTE NEARS."
LOOK CLOSELY.
THAT HEADLINE IS FAKE NEWS.
THERE ARE NO MODERATE DEMOCRATS.
LAST ONE, NEW JERSEY CONGRESSMAN
JEFF VAN DREW'S JUMPING SHIP AND
SWITCHING TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT DOING
A SINGLE THING FOR YOU, THE
PEOPLE, WE THE PEOPLE.
WHAT HAVE THEY DONE IN THREE
YEARS EXCEPT RUSSIA, RUSSIA,
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, MUELLER,
MUELLER, INVESTIGATE,
INVESTIGATE.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE A THING.
30 OTHER DEMOCRATS IN DISTRICTS
DONALD TRUMP WON IN 2016, NOT
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD LAWMAKERS,
THEY SEEM TO BE FOLLOWING
PELOSI, SCHIFF, NADLER RIGHT OFF
THE CLIFF AND WHO CARES WHAT
THEIR CONSTITUENTS THINK.
NO MODERATE POLITICIAN WHATEVER
SUPPORT THIS PARTISAN SHAM.
THERE IS ZERO EVIDENCE.
ONE FACT WITNESS.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG THAT WAS
DONE HERE.
THE ONLY ONE THAT DID SOMETHING
WRONG THAT THEY TOTALLY
COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY IGNORE IS
QUID AND PRO AND QUO JOE WHO
KNEW THAT HIS SON WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED SO HE LEVERAGED A
BILLION TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE BILLING
UNLESS YOU FIRE THE PROSECUTOR
INVESTIGATING MY SON HIS BEING
PAID MILLIONS FOR KNOWING
NOTHING, FOR HAVING ZERO
EXPERIENCE.
YOU'VE GOT SIX HOURS.
SON OF A B.
THEY CAN PRETEND THEY ARE
CARRYING OUT THEIR SOLEMN DUTY
AND THEY ARE DOING IT WITH VERY
PRAYERFUL WAYS.
I DON'T BUY IT.
AS THE PRESIDENT POINTED OUT
PERHAPS MOST TOP
PERHAPS MOST MOP
PERHAPS MOST MOST INSULTING OF
THIS FALSE DISPLAY OF ACTING SO
SOLEMN, YOU APPARENTLY HAVE SO
LITTLE RESPECT FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT YOU EXPECT THEM TO
BELIEVE YOU ARE IN APPROACHING
THE IF YOU'D SPENT SOMBERLY,
RESERVE RELAY, RELUCTANTLY.
NO INTELLIGENT PERSON BELIEVES
THAT.
WE DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
YOU ARE LYING.
CASE IN POINT: WE HAVE THE
COMPROMISE CORRUPT CONGENITAL
LIAR ADAM SCHIFF.
HE'S BEEN BUSY MAKING THE
ROUNDS.
OH, ALL OVER AN EIGHT NIGHT
COMEDY SHOWS.
OF COURSE, THE PERFECT PLACE TO
BE IN SUCH A SOLEMN TIME AND
MOMENT.
LET'S GO WITH THE COMEDY
CIRCUIT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I FEEL LIKE SOMEONE ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, AND WHEN
YOU ARE A DISORGANIZED BILL, IT
MEANS THAT SOMETHING HAS GONE
WRONG.
>> YES, IT CAN.
IN FACT, I HAD A RATHER UNUSUAL
EXPENSE ON MY WAY HERE TONIGHT.
I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH ONE OF
THE MAJOR AIRLINES TRYING TO GET
BACK INTO MY ACCOUNT BECAUSE I
COULDN'T REMEMBER THE PASSWORD
SO I FINALLY GET THROUGH.
>> YOU ARE ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
>> THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS YOUR
FIRST DOG'S NAME.
IF TOO SHORT.
IT WON'T ACCEPT IT.
I SAY IT WON'T ACCEPT MY DOGS
NAME SO THE VOICE SAYS TRY
IMPEACH.
I SAID WHAT?
IT SAYS TRY IMPEACH.
I SAID I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT YOU
SAID.
I WAS TRYING TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL BUT I COULDN'T
HELP.
I SAID I'M NOT GOING TO USE THAT
AS THE DOGS NAME.
>> Sean: CLEARLY FOR SCHIFF
IT'S NOT PART OF ANY SOLEMN
DUTY, HE'S NOT ACTING SO
PRAYERFUL IS MANY DEMOCRATS ARE
APPARENTLY CLAIMING.
IT'S ABOUT FAME AND FORTUNE AND
IRRATIONAL RAGE AND HATRED OF
ALL THINGS TRUMP.
HE IS SERVING HIS OWN SICK
TWISTED EGO AND ONLY HIS EGO.
HIS CONSTITUENTS HAVE HAD
ENOUGH.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY THOUGHT OF THE
SCHIFF SHOW AS A TOWN HALL
DESCENDED INTO ABSOLUTE CHAOS.
THAT IS ADAM SCHIFF'S SHOW.
THAT'S WHAT HE CAUSED BY THE WA
WAY.
BY THE WAY THE LATEST EXAMPLE,
SET EXAMPLE OF HOW HE AND HOW HE
AND THE DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES,
THEY DON'T CARE THEY ARE RIPPING
THIS COUNTRY APART.
THEY CARE NOT ABOUT THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENCY.
THEY CARE NOT ABOUT WHAT THE
WORLD THINKS.
THEY CARE NOT ABOUT ANYTHING
ABOUT HELPING YOU, WE THE
PEOPLE.
THIS IS ABOUT, THIS IS ALL THEY
WANTED TO DO FOR THREE YEARS.
THE BEST PART I CAN SAY TONIGHT
ON THE EVE OF THIS MADNESS THAT
IS HURTING THE COUNTRY IS LET
NOT YOUR HEARTS BE TROUBLED
BECAUSE THIS NOW WILL GO TO THE
U.S. SENATE.
MAJORITY LEADER McCONNELL BE
SERVING DEMOCRATS A HEALTHY DOSE
OF REALITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
WOULD APPARENTLY LIKE OUR
CHAMBER TO DO HOUSE DEMOCRATS'
HOMEWORK FOR THEM.
HE WANTS TO VOLUNTEER THE
SENATE'S TIME AND ENERGY ON A
FISHING EXPEDITION TO SEE
WHETHER HIS OWN IDEAS COULD MAKE
CHAIRMAN SCHIFF SLOPPY WORK MORE
PERSUASIVE.
THEN CHAIRMAN SCHIFF HIMSELF.
BOTHERED TO MAKE IT.
THE CENTAGE IS MEANT TO ACT AS
JUDGE AND JURY TO HEAR A TRIAL,
NOT TO RERUN THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE ANGRY
PARTISANS RUSHED SLOPPILY
THROUGH IT.
>> Sean: AFTER EVERYTHING,
DEMOCRATS HAVE PUT THIS COUNTRY
THROUGH, ABSOLUTELY NOTHING'S
GOING TO CHANGE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REMAINS IN